on passe maintenant notre chronique
juniors tous les mois notre journaliste
mélanie poké nous rejoint sur ce plateau
pour nous à présenter des activités
sportives pour les as tout petit mon
sort mais l'ami on ça alors aujourd'hui
direction lit de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour parler
équitation le centre équestre sky
équitation accueille tous les publics et
même les plus jeunes
mélanie c'est vers ça mais l'école à son
poney club a décidé au moins de 6 ans il
ya du baby poney et un cours moustiques
alors le premier c'est pour les 4-5 ans
le deuxième c'est pour les 2 3 ans un
stage se dérouler pendant les vacances
scolaires de la toussaint
julien guennec et moniteur d'équitation
ça permet de sensibiliser les enfants à
part une semaine autour du poney ça
permet de l'art développé un petit peu
les sens des responsabilités tout ça de
pouvoir s'occuper d'un être vivant
voilà c'est vraiment à quelque chose
c'est vraiment la semaine de stage leur
permet vraiment de s'habituer d'avoir
des bons réflexes avec les animaux alors
comme les grands les cavaliers
découvrent leurs montures les brosses
les prépare et très vite ils montrent
leurs poneys et alterne les petites
activités slalom parcours et même un peu
de voltige donc on a apprend un petit
peu à comment se comporter autour du
poney à les familiariser avec l'animal
et à vaincre un petit peu leur première
appréhension
les premiers contacts avec l'animal et
ensuite c'est vraiment que du ludique on
leur apprend pas forcément de la
technique non leur apprend en s'amusant
alors les vacances de la toussaint sont
terminés mais les activités continuent à
mehdaoui notamment pour les 4-5 ans sky
équitation fait durer le plaisir
les trois dimanches suivants ceux de
novembre donc le baby poney continue de
11h30 à 12h30 et forme peut être les
futurs champions olympiques 1 de demain
mais dhamir merci beaucoup en tout cas